In Swift, structs are much more
powerful than in other languages.
Their capabilities
approach those of classes.
In addition to their own properties,
they can also have their own methods,
and can expand functionality
through extensions and protocols.
Let's take a look at
a couple of examples.
Here's a struct called picture frame.
It has three stored properties.
Width, height and thickness, and
one computed property, area.
As with enumerations structs can
have customized emit methods.
But they also come with automatically
generated member wise initializers,
like this one here.
In this line of code,
I'm initializing a ten by eight
picture frame with a thickness of 1.5.
And this is how I access
the computed property, area, and
up here you can see the area
properties custom getter.
Here's another example, this beer struct
has three stored properties, style,
percent alcohol, and
an international cheers dictionary.
Cheers dict is a type property,
it also has a computed property,
suggested volume per serving.
The volume per serving goes down,
as the alcohol percentage goes up.
Some of the Belgian beers at the pub
around the corner from my house
are super strong.
If I was drinking whole pints of those,
I might be in trouble.
The beer struct also has its
own type method called Cheers.
It takes in a language and prints out
a phrase to toast with in that language.
And this is what initialization
looks like for the beer struct.
Again, I'm using the automatically
generated member y's initializer
to set our style and
percentAlcohol properties.
And here in the sidebar,
you can see that a lager with 6%
alcohol has been instantiated.
As usual,
we can access the computed property,
suggestedVolumePerServing with
dot syntax.
Now I want to open up the console for
a second, so we can see our results.
Remember that because
Cheers is a type method,
we call it on the struct itself,
so we call it on beer.
And then, let's pick a language
we want to toast in,
let's toast in Japanese.
And then we can look over in
our console and see kompai.